hello everyone and welcome to this
month's Enterprise Community Meetup
where we'll discuss another end-to-end
data science workflow using positeam my
name is Ryan Johnson and I'm a data
science advisor here at posit and I'm
joined by a few of my colleagues who
will be hanging out in the YouTube chat
during the webinar and we'll stick
around afterward to answer any questions
you may have about the content we'll go
over today
as a reminder this is a recurring event
on the last Wednesday of every month and
the goal is to provide the data science
Community with an overview of posit team
these demos are open to everyone and the
attendance over the past few months has
been awesome but feel free to share
these webinars with your colleagues
friends or anyone else that is looking
to improve their own data science
workflows with positive tools
now for this month's topic we're going
to focus on how to create a fast API in
Python and then show how this API can
more or less build Bridges between the
various steps of your data science
workflow
now before we dive into creating a fast
API let's quickly review posit team
positive is a bundled offering of our
three professional data science tools
posit workbench posit connect and posit
package manager
now taking a look at the diagram on your
screen will start at the very top with
the data analyst who will be writing
code and creating insights using posit
workbench
they can choose to write code in either
r or Python and they have a variety of
Ides to choose from including our studio
cheaper lab Jupiter notebooks and vs
code
for our developers they may be creating
content such as shiny applications pins
are markdown or plumber apis
and for python developers they may be
creating content such as flask or fast
apis streamlit shiny or Dash
applications pins or Jupiter notebooks
once the content is created the
developers will need a way to easily
share that content with the people that
need to see it and that's where posit
connect comes into play
connect not only makes your content
shareable but also gives your team tight
control over content access
finally we have a posit package manager
which does exactly as this name implies
and that's to host organize and
distribute open source R and python
packages not only from the community but
also any internally developed r or
python packages
for today's workflow
we will use vs code from within posit
workbench to develop a fast API in
Python and to keep things nice and
simple we're going to design this API to
do only one thing and that's to serve
data
we'll then publish this fast API to
posit connect and show how it can serve
as a gateway to your data which can be
accessed by multiple pieces of content
using python or or any other language or
system
now many of you may be like me and when
you started your data science Journey
the idea of working with apis let alone
creating your own API was so daunting
that I honestly try to avoid working
with apis at all costs well I'm here to
tell you that they're not that scary and
can actually be used to vastly improve
your data science workflows
now the acronym API stands for
application programming interface and
they essentially allow communication
between applications
to help explain what apis are I like to
think of the commonly used restaurant
analogy you see on your screen here
we have three customers that have
entered a restaurant and would like to
order some food that the chef in the
kitchen will prepare
to request Foo the customers need some
way to communicate their order to the
kitchen and rarely if ever the customer
will interact directly with the chef
so that's where the waiter or waitress
comes into play they take the order from
the customer and can communicate that
order to the chef the chef prepares the
food which is then delivered back to the
customer
so in this analogy the waiter a waitress
allows for communication between the
customers and the chef essentially they
are the API
for data scientists apis can be an
essential workflow building block that
gives other users our applications or
systems the ability to interact with the
functions you've designed the models
you've trained or the data you've
curated
you also don't need to be a software
engineer or computer scientist to create
an API and there are numerous Frameworks
in both R and python for creating apis
including plumber and flask
now for today's workflow we're going to
focus on just a fast API which is one of
the most popular Frameworks for creating
apis using python given its Simplicity
and performance
now as I previously mentioned the fast
API we are going to build today and
publish to posit connect will
essentially serve as a gateway to our
data which can be accessed by a variety
of content
but like why would you want to do this
well there are a few reasons the first
reason is that it simplifies your code
you no longer need to attach and read in
and transform the data into each
individual piece of content so this
helps also prevent data duplication and
also standardize data access across
content
secondly by putting data behind an API
it makes it easily accessible to
different content types
for example you can have a jupyter
notebook built using python and a shiny
application built using R access the
same data via the same API and later on
in this demo we'll demonstrate this
capability
lastly by publishing the fast API to
posit connect you can control access to
your data by adding an authentication
layer to your apis and this is a great
option if your team is working with
sensitive data
now we are very close to building our
fast API but I just want to spend one
minute and explain the data we're going
to have behind this API
this data is completely made up and I
wanted to make it as simple as possible
given our limited time today
now this data it's also it's relatively
small it's only about 500 rows and has
only two columns so the First Column is
a random letter in the English alphabet
and the second column is a random number
from 1 to 20. and that's pretty much it
as we go through today's demo I want you
to think about where your data lives
today in this workflow our data is going
to live as a local CSV file
but maybe your data lives in a database
or a shared network drive or maybe as a
pin on posit connect
by using an API to access the data no
matter where it lives we can standardize
how the data is accessed across your
various pieces of content and your
entire data science team
okay so let's build our fast API on this
slide is all the code needed to create a
simple data Gateway fast API and as you
can see it's less than 20 lines of code
in the first three lines of code we will
import the libraries modules and
functions needed for this workflow
including fast API itself the typing
module for hinting at content types and
finally the pandas library for reading
and manipulating our data
we next create the fast API instance
using the fast API function which we'll
call app in this example
now the first step of our API is to read
in the data as a data frame using the
read CSV function from pandas
well then store our data frame as a
variable called largedf
next we Define our API endpoint now an
endpoint takes in the API request which
is usually a URL processes it and sends
back a response
for our fast API we are using a git
method for our endpoint which is
routinely used to read data
the forward slash followed by the word
data tells the fast API that anything
following the forward slash data in the
request URL are parameters to the API
which can be fed into the function
directly below
and finally we have the function itself
this is where all the logic of your fast
API lives
an hour fast API we are defining a
single function called get filtered data
and it takes a single argument called
letters
letters are captured as a list of
strings when the API is queried
it's also an optional query item and
defaults to none if no letters are
provided
so we next use the list of letters to
filter our data
and if I simply read this code left to
right top to bottom we start by asking
if the query contained any letters if
yes the data is then filtered for those
specific letters and returned by the
function
if no letters are provided it simply
Returns the entire data set itself
so now that we have all the code needed
I'm going to copy it to my clipboard
and then navigate over to positive
workbench
so here's the home page for posit
workbench and you can see that I
currently have three separate sessions
running
I have a vs code session in our studio
session and a Jupiter notebook session
so I'm going to first navigate into this
vs code session which I currently have
open another tab so I'll click on that
and once here you'll notice that I'm
currently within a directory I called
Fast API demo and I previously created a
virtual environment in this directory
which is called Dot venv and I'm first
going to activate this virtual
environment so to do that I'm going to
open up a new terminal I'll click on
these three lines in the top left corner
it's like terminal and new terminal
and once we have our prompt I want to
Source the activate script within that
virtual environment so VNV bin activate
and hit enter
oh spell Source wrong let's go ahead and
fix that
and there we go I now have my virtual
environment activated and this is
typically best practice and it's a great
idea just to ensure that the work we do
here is isolated from any other project
currently on posit workbench
so let's go ahead and create a new
python file by clicking the new file
button which you can find again clicking
on these three lines file new file
I'm going to call this main dot Pi hit
enter we're going to place in our
current working directory hit okay
you can see it show up here on the file
explorer and now we have our file which
is completely empty let's go ahead and
paste in that fast API
so now that it's been been created let's
go ahead and show you how to publish
this fast API to posit Connect using the
RS connect python package which I
previously installed into this
environment
so the RS connect python package it
provides a command line interface so you
can use it within the terminal down here
for deploying content to posit connect
so I'm going to type out the command
here in the command line and I'm going
to explain each step along the way
so we first need to I'll make my screen
a little bit bigger here we first need
to tell RS connect
to deploy a fast API
next we need to indicate which posit
connect instance we will be deploying to
now I previously saved this connect
instance into my environment and I gave
it the name PCT prod so all we need to
do is give it the name dash n PCT prod
and then finally we just need to provide
the name and location of the fast API
so this main file it lives in my current
working directory which we can indicate
with a period and then we just have to
provide the name of the file hit enter
and that's pretty much it
so this is going to kick off the
publishing process to the RS connect
python package it's essentially taking a
snapshot of my environment including
what packages are my environment package
versions what python version am I using
it sends that information to pause it
from posit workbench to pause it connect
and then it deploys this fast API and so
we'll just give this a few more seconds
to publish
and there we go it's all done and we get
these two links down here and so I'm
gonna go ahead and click on the
dashboard content and that will navigate
us directly to posit connect
now once it's deployed we can now
interact with this fast API on Connect
using this Swagger interface that you
see on your screen
our API it only has one git endpoint and
we can try querying it using various
letters in the alphabet and seeing the
resulting API response
so let's try querying this fast API to
extract all of the a rows in the data
set so I'll select get right here and
we'll try it out
and here we can add letters
so I'll add an a here and then we can
hit execute and once we hit execute the
Swagger interface it'll show you the
curl command that was run to Ping the
API
the request URL which is right here and
then if we scroll down we can see the
response which is in this Json format
where each row of the data is a chunk of
this Json file
let's try a few different combinations
just to make sure that the API is
behaving correctly so let me come back
up here to the top and we'll add an
additional string item so maybe we'll do
let's try T and we'll also try M hit
execute
and we can see the curl response the
request URL
and here we can see the response where
it's just T's and M's
now A major benefit of this API hosted
on posit connect is that you can manage
who has access to it which is shown
right over here
if I select any of the options that
require authentication including this
bottom option for specific users or
groups or the middle option all users
login required then users of the API
would essentially need to provide an API
key in order to leverage this API and
that API key you can actually log into
connect click on your name and generate
those keys right over here
so now that we have the fast API hosted
on connect let's use it as a Gateway for
multiple pieces of content using both R
and python
and let's actually start with python in
a Jupiter notebook so let's come back to
posit workbench so we have our three
sessions currently running and I'm going
to open up this Jupiter notebook session
which I have opening a separate tab here
and here's a Jupiter notebook that I
created
so in this notebook this first code
chunker here we have a few packages and
libraries we need for this analysis
specifically this request Library which
is going to be important for pinging our
API so let's run this code chunk
and the next code chunk right down here
we're going to use that request library
to submit a git query to our API so you
can see that request URL right here
and we're going to feed in two
parameters so we're essentially going to
extract data where the letters columns
equal to f g or R so let's go ahead and
run this
and we're going to take that Json
response and we're going to convert it
into a data frame using the pandas
package so we'll run this code chunk and
you can see the output of that
the query for the API
and then finally we're going to take
this resulting data frame that we
received from the API and we're going to
create a plot to visualize it and we do
that using the Swarm plot from the
Seaborn package in Python
so also it's just worth noting that I
didn't have to manually upload and
filter the data you know the fast API
does this for us
so that's how to query the API from
within a python Jupiter notebook let's
actually switch gears to the r language
and call the API from within a shine
application
so I'm going to come back here to posit
workbench and we'll open up this rstudio
session which again I have open in
another tab
which is right here
now we won't go in depth regarding the
underlying or shiny code here but I do
want to show how the fast API is being
queried from within this shiny
application
so here in the top left corner this is
the shiny application it's nothing but R
code which is used to create interactive
web applications
so we're going to use the shiny package
for this but also note that we're using
this Json Lite and HTTR package to
interact with our API
so I'm going to scroll down here to the
server function and just highlight a few
lines of code which is going to be
important for pinging our API
so this first bit of code right here
this is where we actually ping that API
so we feed it that API URL which I saved
as a variable and we can provide some
query parameters to that API
we then take that response all right We
Gather it here and then we convert that
Json response into a data frame which
will eventually be converted over to a
tibble we save that as a response data
which gets fed into a GG plot
so let's go ahead and run this shiny
application so you can see how it works
so the first thing you'll see here is
this input box and this is where we can
choose as many letters as we want so
I'll select a few letters we'll do C J
and let's do p as well
and once we have the letters selected we
can then query the API by clicking on
this box
and then once we do that you can see it
returns a plot that's very similar to
the plot we saw in a jupyter notebook we
would have letters along the x-axis and
the corresponding numbers along the
y-axis
so that's pretty much it so hopefully
this was a a good way to show how you
can ping the same API and access the
same data set from different content
types written in two separate languages
so now that you know a bit more about
how apis specifically fast apis work we
hope that you can take this knowledge
and incorporate it into your own data
science workflows
so thanks again everybody for joining
today and feel free to stick around if
you have any questions about what we
talked about today otherwise have a
great rest of your day and we hope to
see you again next month
thanks so much Ryan as Ryan mentioned
we're gonna stick around for some q a
for another 15 minutes or so YouTube
should automatically push you over to
that but I know that wasn't as
straightforward last month so I've also
included the link in the details below
in the YouTube description and we'll
also copy that over to the chat right
now too as a reminder there's also a
slido open for anonymous questions and
so that's at POS dot i t slash demo Dash
questions and we'll keep that open for
the rest of the week as well and we can
add the answers there in slido2 but
thank you again for joining us today and
we'll see you over there in the Q a